kongresstag korn achter guten morgen
lukas gedacht das ist gerade 8 und 32
ich habe gleich einen arzttermin und
falls ihr den letzten noch gesehen haben
ist mir dass ich da den forschern haben
das heißt man muss ich mit meinem mini
widerfahren
doch da der mittlerweile circa einer
woche danach diese ekelhafte spinne ihr
in dem bad was willst du hier eigentlich
alter da ich jetzt gleich wieder so ein
rad im test beim arzt habe von meiner
mutter und sagte ja so dass sich zähne
geputzt habe nicht
der arzt vorbei alles geklappt und jetzt
regieren oder blätter mit wasser und
freunde guckt euch das essen nahmen
arzttermin und landschaft kann ich das
gerade mal im harz termin und lunch ist
beendet ich falsch zurück nach hause
ich bin wieder zu hause angekommen ich
glaube ich werde das ist mal eine
richtig fette wurst hier in bagdad eine
richtig fette wurst gelegt ich habe mir
übrigens gerade als noch unterwegs war
zwei neue klamotten teile eingekauft
einmal hier sollen kam flasche wisst ihr
was wir machen ist eine modenschau
meine damen und herren sehen sie
reinkamen klarstellen von tpg wenige
tragen von laser auf dem laufsteg heute
sehr schönes hemd und hier meine damen
und herren sehen sie einen stone eines
reverse findet mit games eine sehr
schöne jacke kann auch gewendet werden
sowie dass wir gerade sehen und ja das
wäre doch schon das ende der heutigen
modenschau
walter ohne spaß im und aus vorbei und
ich gucke einfach mal kurz nach draußen
und auf einmal war es ist fucking dunkel
der längste tag im jahr ist glaube ich
der einundzwanzigste juni und der
kürzeste tag der 21
dezember das heißt wir sind direkt
dazwischen alter ist es beängstigend wie
schnell der sommer vorbei gehen ich habe
vor ein paar stunden twitter posts
verfasst wo ihr mir als antworten des
aufnehmen sollte
gegen mich und das wollte ich jetzt
eigentlich wir müssen darauf reagieren
aber es ist jetzt dunkel deswegen würde
ich sagen lässt sich jetzt erst mal was
und dann reagiere ich einfach morgen auf
diese verschiedenen sachen also für euch
sogar noch in diesem blog halt einfach
ein paar minuten ich jetzt allerdings
vorschlag meine damen und herren das ist
erst sehen uhr aber ich muss morgen um
acht uhr aufstehen weil ich dann renne
magenspiegelungen habe ich gar kein wort
das ist auch der grund warum ich nicht
das hat auch beim arzt war
dort musste ich nämlich guten taten
tests machen und morgens magenspiegelung
bei der letzten zeit egal was ich esse
ich habe so ein bisschen bauchschmerzen
also hey das war leichter wenn ihr auch
schon mal was gegessen habe ich würde
jetzt aber auf jeden fall erstmal guten
morgen du was geht ab es ist gerade 7.15
und ich muss gleich zum magenspiegelung
mich darauf jetzt eher weniger ich habe
jetzt auch geduscht verfügt
dementsprechend schon ein bisschen
fitter heute so früh am morgen
und es regnet legal deutschland mann ich
bin kein arzt oder im internet stand
davon eine magenspiegelung komplett
problemlos abläuft also man sich dann
quasi hin und kriegt unseren deutschen
bank für das gar nicht vorstellen auf
jeden fall dort das angeblich nur ein
paar minuten also ich habe den termin
jetzt welche macht und reißt das heißt
es kann sein dass ich daran gibt habe
und dann bin ich direkt nach dem pech
und bleibe trotzdem nicht ein bisschen
angst davor meine mutter fällt mir jetzt
jedenfalls erst mal zum arzt weil ich
bekomme da voraus und die spritze das
bis plötzlich mit krieg und dann habe
ich 24 stunden keine maschinen bedienen
wird auf jeden fall sagen wird es gleich
wieder wenn das ganze vorbei ist wir
sind jetzt fertig mit der
magenspiegelung das hat jetzt
tatsächlich in minute 56 bedauert ich
habe vorher seine das spritzen bekommen
dass ich als die hälfte nichts mehr mit
werke was wollte ich noch sagen bin
enorm wacklig auf den beinen als sich
aufgestiegen bin und ich wollte
eigentlich gar nicht laufen und wollte
stehen bleiben
meine beine breit das ist gerade
irgendwie so nicht zu beschreiben nicht
ich weiß jetzt ein bisschen so wie wenn
man betrunken ist aber auch so als der
mann trampolin gesprungen und dann
wieder auf einem normalen boden zurück
geht versteht ihr irgendwie was ich
meine der arzt meinte jetzt auf jeden
fall das nicht zu hause bin ich erstmal
schlafen sollte wird es ihnen dass ich
ihn geschlagen holen würde und ich bin
da auch halb eingeschlafen gerade die
bei genauer vor
meine mutter meinte gar nicht so lässt
man den genauen vorgang was jetzt gerade
ab liegt hier auf youtube mitteilen weil
alle meinen dass ich heute abend für
sich heute fast dahin fall meinten dass
ich heute abend das alles wieder
vergessen habe also es liegt heute abend
beim arzt und
als erstes passierte zunächst einmal
habe ich die spitze mit kommen in den
abend und die mit blut abgenommen haben
dann haben die mir eine was war das
regierung eine sedierung zugefügt so
dass ich mit mir ich musste
so dass ich schließlich werde und dann
meinte der sehr und wirkte schon ich
gucke nicht nur zweimal ich dachte wie
auch dass wir gute kameraposition dann
musste ich mich auf die seite legen also
quasi so rüber in die stabile seitenlage
und dann haben wir halt so ein fettes
ding vor allem und gepackt und dahinter
und habe ich gefühlt dass weder und dann
ging es los und ich habe aber alles
gemerkt dass ich habe gemerkt wie der
schlauch war sie rund haben weil sie
meinen dass er so ich hoffe dass das
video macht sind seien glücklich dass es
geklappt hat es um auf den punkt zu
kommen ist es auf jeden jetzt nicht mehr
diesen charakter hier aus war das ganze
hat anhalt gegen diese fünf minuten
gedauert und während dieser schlauch bei
mir halt war habe ich einen trecker zehn
mal so gemacht und gesagt stopp und
keine ahnung was und
die aber nicht gestoppt auf jeden fall
habe ich jetzt erst mal nach hause
ich bin so ein bisschen knapp ich auf
den beinen deswegen werde ich heute 24
stunden dann kein auto kämpfen dürfen
weiter und so fort aber privatjet
einfliegen
wir sehen uns zu hause wieder stark
jetzt erstmal durchsagen sehen wir uns
wieder und ich wollte euch das gleich
noch mal so ein bisschen darstellen wie
das beim arzt gerade abgelaufen ist es
auch keinen schauspiel wenn ich weiß ich
bin ich kein schauspieler
ja freunde wenn ich mal auf die uhr
gucken ist es halb zwei ich habe gerade
einfach mal so drei bis vier stunden
geschlafen ich wollen gesagt weil ich
das ganze noch mal so sitcom mäßig so
ein bisschen schauspiel mäßig hier da
stellen wir uns ganz passiert ist aber
da ich jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal
schon mal viel fitter bin will ich jetzt
eine kleinigkeit essen und zwar überholt
das erst mal dass ich seit 17 stunden
das essen und warme brötchen mit
spiegelt aber diese war schon ein
bisschen eltern
[Musik]
hallo lokal ich nehme jetzt ein bisschen
blut tag und dann bekommst du eine
spritze mit
das dachte ich mir bereits
so ich habe ihn jetzt blut abgenommen
und jetzt schlafen sie bitte ok mache
ich herr doktor professor ist
ich bin jetzt war sie sind jetzt mach
ich würde jetzt ja sie sind jetzt machen
und wir sind jetzt auch schon fertig ist
dann habe ich ja die ganze zeit
geschlafen wo gar nichts mitbekommen
aber sie sind jetzt leider oft oben und
dürfen 24 stunden nicht fahren
ok facto ich weiß nach hause wohin gehen
sie sie dürfe doch nicht fahren ich mir
scheiß egal ob
[Musik]
okay ganz so ließ dann doch nicht ab
aber zumindest geteilt als nicht wen ich
in meinem eigenen bett und ich hatte
auch nicht diese sache dran und ich habe
auch nicht um also jetzt lief eigentlich
komplett anders ab aber ich wollte die
sitcom wochen auf jeden fall haben
gestern schon gesagt beziehungsweise für
euch im blog jetzt kommt ein paar
minuten dass ich auf ein paar diss
tracks reagiert wollte die ihren mich
verfasst habe deswegen würde ich sagen
haben wir mit dem ersten distrikt
waterberg so habe ich mir das jetzt eher
nicht vorgestellt wenn absätze sind
höher als das nietzsche kongresstag
achter ist so fett deine göttl länge ist
der äquator den lustlos im internet luca
droht
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht was
jetzt schwimmen im brot ist also ich war
nicht schon auf meinen hier mit meinem
einzigen freund im brot deswegen würde
ich sagen fragen was er von mir hält hey
wie findest du mich eigentlich so bist
ein kleiner vollidiot ich liebe meine
freundin es konzerte verteilt das hast
du bestimmt einfach auf den clown hat
mit der kamera geredet es ist kürzen
kann die wahrheit sagen wenn du auch ein
klo sitzt einem dummen blog macht
brauchst du eh nicht zensieren wenn du
das leider nicht okay
die autostadt netzwerk hast du im bbc
also das ist doch jedes umgeguckt da
muss man ganz kurz was du klar stellen
und zwar an dass ich ein vollidiot bin
okay das eigentlich selber sei relativ
häufig in meinen blogs aber dass jeder
hund sagen würde dass ich ihn voll du
bist ein kleiner vollidiot wollen wir
jetzt zum letzten lauf den ich heute
reagieren wollte und zwar ist es
wirklich ein adler kann wirklich
eigentlich mithalten amerikaner kann
jack bauer nicht mithalten die ganzen
amerikaner in ganz anderen engländer
muss ich wirklich sagen das ist ein witz
der hat mich hier berührt es ist jetzt
nichts was irgendwie total beschissen
war oder irgendwie du denn das war
echtes das ging tief vom herzen aus
wieder das an mich
einsame spitze
das war es jetzt hier von luca reagiert
doch dass ich dachte eigentlich dass bis
tracks com also nicht irgendwelche
sprüche sondern quasi irgendwelche rap
liga auf irgendwelchen instrument ist
oder so aber das war vielleicht ein
anderes mal die sonne steht schon
relativ tief dass wir relativ tief was
ist daran so lustig mir fällt gerade
erst mal auf die grasgrünen meine augen
einfach sind und in meinem herz steht
einfach ja blaugrau alter ich glaube ich
kümmere mich ein termin beim bürgeramt
ist das bürgeramt idee ist scheiße gar
nicht erst jetzt auf jeden fall was los
ist
[Musik]
das meine damen und herren wir gerade
mein neuer fortschritt bei faded von
allen borg ich taste mich ja immer so
ein schritt für schritt an das komplette
bild run auf jeden fall ist jetzt
mittlerweile auch schon 10 uhr das ist
für mich in letzter zeit ist schon
relativ spät dann auf jeden fall den ich
jetzt erst mal die zähne putzen
[Musik]
ich würde dieser stelle den heutigen
blog jetzt allerdings auch beenden ich
hoffe hat euch gefallen wird etwas getan
hat las auch gern gefolgt wo eure
freunde bad taste die geht's auf jeden
fall mittlerweile schon viel besser nach
der magenspiegelung heute morgen also
kurz nachdem das passiert weil ich habe
voll am arsch irgendwie aber jetzt bin
ich nicht auf jeden fall schon wieder
fit mich hat jetzt sogar schöner 80
stunden schlafen und dann werde ich
morgen mittag zurück nach köln fahren
falls ihr aber noch keine wurden von
einem kanal sein könnte einfach unter
dem video abonnieren kriegen dann
verpasst du gerne videos wird wenn ich
schon abonnent seid dann könnt ihr auf
die glocke klicken denn dann bekommt die
benachrichtigung auf euer handy sobald
ich immer einen neuen blog hochladen ab
dem bock wenn ich wieder in köln dass
sich eine welt voll auf mein komplettes
video wieder sims hochladen weil ich
habe mir das in letzter zeit bei manu
und halle angekommen das war nicht ganz
coole da habe ich gedacht na ich lade
alle drei monate man hoch vielleicht
kann ich das noch mal wieder machen es
erwähnen dass du hast mir leid schreibt
sims in die kommentare und sonst würde
ich sagen sehen wir uns dann in einem
weiteren video demnächst wieder
[Musik]